liz's math test included a survey
question asking how many hours students
spent studying for the test
the scatter plot below shows the
relationship between how many hours
students spend studying and their score
on the test
a line was fit to the data to model the
relationship they don't tell us how the
line was fit but this actually looks
like a pretty good fit if i just eyeball
it
which of these linear equations best
describes the given model so as you know
this point right over here this shows
that some student at least self-reported
they studied a little bit more than half
an hour and they didn't actually do that
well on the test looks like they scored
a 43 or 44 on the test this right over
here shows or like this one over here is
a student who says they studied two
hours and it looks like they scored
about a 64 65 on the test and
this over here or this over here looks
like a study a student who studied over
four hours where they reported that and
they got looks like a 95 or 96 on the
exam and so then and these are all the
different students each of these points
is represents a student and then they
fit a line and when they say which of
these linear equations best describes
the given model they're really saying
which of these linear equations
describes or is or or is being plotted
right over here by this line that's
trying to fit to them that's trying to
fit to the data
so essentially we just want to figure
out what is the equation of this line
well it looks like the y-intercept right
over here is 20 and it looks like all of
these choices here have a y-intercept of
20. so that doesn't help us much but
let's think about what the slope is when
we increase by one when we increase
along our x-axis by one so change in x
is 1. what is our change in y
our change in y
looks like let's see we went from 20 to
40. it looks like we got went up by 20.
so our change in y over change in x for
this model for this line that's trying
to fit to the data is 20 over 1. so this
is going to be our slope and if we look
at all of these choices only this one
has a slope of 20. so it would be this
choice
right over here
based on this equation
estimate the score for a student that
spent 3.8 hours studying so we would go
to 3.8 which is right around see this
would be
3.8 would be right around here so let's
estimate that score so if i go straight
up where do we intersect our model where
do we intersect our line
so it looks like they would get a pretty
high score let's see if i were to take
it to the vertical axis
it looks like they would get about a 97
so i would write
my estimate is that they would get a 97
based on this model and once again this
is only a model it's not a guarantee
that if someone studies 3.8 hours
they're going to get a 97 but it could
give an indication of what maybe
might be a reasonable to expect assuming
the the time studying is is the variable
that matters but you also have to be
careful with these models because it
might imply if you kept going that if
you get if you study for if you study
for nine hours you're gonna get a 200 on
the exam even though something like that
is impossible so you always have to be
careful extrapolating with models and
keep it take it with a grain of salt
this is just a model that's trying to
fit to this data and you might be able
to use it to
to estimate things or to maybe set some
form of an expectation but take it all
with a grain of salt